from the post to millennial woke New
York attorney general Democrat lawmakers
to host drag queen's story event for
families the event is set to feature
drag performers reading to children so
now you have in New York state sponsored
Dragon shows for kids I can't get past
the why do you demand that drag
performers read to Children
then you know the answer I do yeah but
the thing is the average person should
at least be asking the question as
opposed to saying well this is what I'm
supposed to be doing so all the Cairns
just decide to show up so that way they
can get the the Kudos at the at the PTA
in their in their academic paper they
wrote the goal is to get glitter in the
carpet that can never be removed quite
literally outlining in their paper trans
pedagogy how to groom children that's
what's the instructions once you do that
you you open the door to nothing being
better or worse than anything else so
being trans being non-binary be being a
forest elf whatever you think you are is
equally good to being a CIS hat person
who who you know has a family and makes
babies and that destroys the ability for
the culture to say anything is better
than anything else it's all equally fine
people people are saying look I don't
want to act like
Rhonda said is pulling a liquor license
from the Hyatt is literal nothing it's
the bare minimum I'll take it I'm not
I'm not mad that he did it okay I'm
happy something is happening but you
have in Florida them saying you're a
large establishment and we're going to
take away your liquor license even
though your principal business is
selling hotel rooms and doing
large-scale events I suppose losing your
liquor license for large-scale events
can be painful meanwhile on the other
side New York is like we're going to
State sponsor all this stuff if they're
in while California is doing the same
thing so if you think this is winning
the culture War you will lose we will
lose and in 10 years you'll be wondering
why your state of Florida is the capital
of child drag shows
well but isn't it also going to drive
people to self-separate into tribes
again okay if New York is where the
state sponsors drag queen Story Hour in
Florida you at least are starting to
stigmatize it and starting to pre-create
consequences for people who perpetrate
it then guess what more people are going
to leave more taxpayers more productive
people are going to leave New York which
is good
here's the thing we are a nation of weak
men we have for too long have we've gone
from the classical liberal sense of Live
and Let Live into the do whatever you
want for whatever reason leave me alone
there's a big difference between Live
and Let Live and do whatever you want
but leave me alone we used to have
shared moral foundations and so our
country was like look
go to your house do your thing but then
if they did things that were considered
bad or destructive the bigger picture we
would still be like either shun or
criminal charges depending on the
severity of the things they were doing
even so so the point is like drug use
and things like that but now we've gone
so far to the anyone can do anything
they want this the country is ripping in
half where you've got adult men putting
on sex shows let me hear Let pull this
up pull up pull it up let me show you
the picture there there there's there's
a drag queen with fake breasts and
children were present there's videos of
it
faith and and doing weird sex things at
this show so New York's going to allow
it and what's going to happen is the men
in New York are going to say I don't
care you can do whatever you want and I
think it's even worse you said I want to
do whatever I want leave me alone it's
not leave me alone it's celebrate my
freakishness you know now you have to
actually have the kids because it's got
the kids participating in Pride parades
and carrying flags and doing all that so
they're telling them it's not just there
if you want to teach kids what is good
what do you celebrate we celebrate pride
month you know so you've got an entire
month where you're telling them these
people who are abnormal I'm not saying
they're bad people but they're outside
the norm of society and they're doing
things that may or may not be healthy
and you're telling kids that's something
to celebrate you know what's funny is
that uh the rainbow is the symbol of
God's covenant to to man that you will
never flood the Earth again and they
decide to I want it back I know that's
but it's also funny that they have pride
celebrations which of course is one of
the seven deadly sins so I I wonder I
wonder I wonder if a lot of it is
intended to attack religion and
Christianity because like you said James
Lindsay is great at pointing out that
it's Praxis all right these these are
things they're doing purposely because
they're attacking the things that are
cohesive and hold a society together and
they're purposely targeting the things
like a nuclear family and the the CIS
hat normality as something to be
destroyed and it's working satisfied
people do not Revolt you don't get a
revolution when you have a society full
of people that are happy drag Story Hour
the nonprofit that's co-sponsoring the
New York AG Story Hour in their mission
statement they have this line that says
uh we capture the imagination and play
of gender fluidity in childhood and give
kids glamorous positive and unabashedly
queer role models for the nonprofit like
they know why they are preaching to
children and they're watching co-opting
childhood we see as innocent say oh well
actually children are gender fluid
that's that's in their basic bio they
assume that all children are gender
fluid which is weird that's not what I
mean it's abnormal and they're they get
on TV they get nothing but Dad is an
idiot right mom should run things and
the gay couple is cooler yeah you know
so all all of the the things are now
designed to push you towards one thing
and and it's working you know and the
fact that we're at least having this
conversation the fact that there's at
least a liquor license in Jeopardy and
hopefully someone will be in handcuffs
is a step in the right direction but it
is a baby step and we need much bigger
steps how how is it that we've gone from
what do you think would have happened 40
years ago
if something like this was done if they
had an event like this with Children
what do you think the governments would
have done I don't think the governments
would have been involved because we
still had culture then we still had a
culture where parents would have been
responsible and they would have shown up
and whoever was doing that would have
had a very sad day you know you think
people in the community would show up
and there would be a riot yeah so baby
steps you're you're I think you're
mistaken this isn't baby steps this is
total and complete surrender yeah that's
it the fact that we've gone from a
society that says we won't allow this to
a society that says well I guess I can
put your liquor license that means we've
retreated and surrendered the fight
completely and and this is Rhonda
Sanders being like I guess I'll do this
I don't know I I don't want to believe
that it's a surrender but I agree with
you that if it's a counter-attack it is
far from let's put it this way on a
scale of one to ten if 40 Years of the
reaction would have been a 10 going in
arresting people shutting it down news
reporting it Angry parents screaming how
could you let this happen today we're
not even at a one we're off the scale
the scale is gone
5.4 somewhere and that's something and
that means we have completely retreated
from the fight period and all that's
left is one city in Florida that's a
nice thing about it because even Texas
won't yeah
there you go I mean that's it we're
talking about shame I think it's
interesting that parents won't shame
each other for taking their kids to the
show in fact Phil's probably right
they're like looking to score points at
the next PTA meeting they're looking to
say well look at this fun experience
we're so I don't know open-minded I
guess our kids being exposed to all
kinds of things it's it's weird I think
40 years ago we would have had more
cultural pressure it wouldn't just be
your neighbors being like you're taking
your kid where it would have been the
grandparents it would have been the
church it would have been everyone in
alignment saying this is not something
we do it's not just the government
intervention but it's the social
intervention think about the incentive
think about the incentive moms are
incentivized to not make waves because
it makes problems for their kids in
school if you're a kid going to school
and your mom and everyone around like
okay so no I know this is going to be
sound awkward to or sound odd to some of
the people sort of our viewers ears but
like if you're a mom and your anti-vaxx
and everybody around you is is up to
date and your kid isn't vaccinated your
kid is going to take endless amounts of
crap at school moms will do a lot of
stuff and shut their mouths about a lot
of things to make sure that their kids
have a a reasonable time at school and
it's it's probably the wrong answer but
that's a significant portion of why
these things tend to metastasize and
spread the way they do well and you can
understand why you wouldn't want to put
the uh the pressure of the political
fight on your third grader right like
absolutely but I've got to move then all
right that's why tribalism and
federalism are our friend there is no
common ground right now yes we have
retreated yes we have surrendered yes we
now need to organize into communities of
like-minded people who will not put up
with that crap and so I don't care I
don't want to hear your job won't let
you move I don't want to hear anything
about it move someplace or change your
own community at the lowest level and at
least fight back yourself and I think
there's some people are doing it I
typically agree with you but then I I
think even moving doesn't escape you
from the internet right so like there's
a family Vlog channel it's getting a lot
of attention right now because they're
talking about their child is
transitioning and they're documenting
taking it to the clinic and whatever it
is and like that means that even if you
moved if your child has access to the
internet this is still the alternative
and you know but if you're in a
homeschool Co-op and all the kids in
that Co-op are hearing from their
parents that that's not how we do things
how do you protect from June no you
can't you can't stop how do you protect
your kid from the from the whole month
it gets coming and it's going to be and
it's gonna drive down your street and
every restaurant has a pride yeah LGBT
shoved right down your throat every June
for like how do you protect your kid
from that I'd like to hope that like it
it empowers parents today to be really
open and honest about their values with
their kids I think there are Generations
where parents didn't want to tell their
kids too much and didn't want to seem
like they were oppressing them or you
know whatever I was like I have a number
of friends whose parents grew up really
religious they the parents then didn't
really bring them church and now the
kids crave that they crave more
Direction like I think in some ways we
might see a redirection but it is
difficult to completely separate
yourself from culture you have to have
an answer for when your kid says like
well why does my friend go to this and
we don't no matter what it is but it's a
we have answers our answers are better
than theirs right their answer is the
more freakish it is the better it is
celebrate the weird but they don't
present it that way you can say that and
you it's obviously it's a difficult
thing but again look at there's also
counter attacks going look at the number
of states now that are Banning surgery
on minors for any kind of transition
they're banning hormones they're banning
the rest of that that's happening more
places so there is because of the
success they've had in pushing that more
people have had to face the fact that
that's going to happen to their kids and
it's happening in their neighborhood and
that's causing a backlash thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time